welcome to this video round 3 coverage
of the candidates tournament in
cantonment disc and this game examined
this video is the game on draken against
ka ogen um yeah you need to check what
the players did before to better
evaluate this game both players some
lost in round two rockin lost on his
game against them kramnik in this
intense battle in the Queens gambit
accepted when I draken lost with black
as well against below played an
excellent game against and rake in
Sicilian Kalashnikov so both players
suffered a loss in the rob before now n
minus 1 so very m moura start for this
tournament and certainly a second loss
is the end for the end of all hopes so
certainly both the players maybe want to
try a bit but certainly don't want to
risk it all because as mentioned the
second loss is basically the end of all
so let's see what happened I draken
place 1.e4 he had played one deform in
the first round against chronic so he
has both moves in his repertoire and
kayaking goes for the balloon defense in
the in the wave not a super exciting
choice but the villainous nowadays one
of the absolute main lines of double
king phone it's an extremely solid then
black gum experiences little theoretical
problem so it's an understandable choice
still it's not very exciting most of the
time I drinking now place d3 which is
very often seen nowadays people really
am failed to show anything in this
and the classic Berlin Wall end game
check it seems that black is holding his
own yeah it's a d3 again as we have seen
in the world championship match last
year and also in some later games Bishop
c5 the main move just developing the
bishop to a good square and now see
three yeah here both cards and Arnold
have played Bishop takes c6 and they
played this this structure we have for
instance cards and want a really
impressive game in the tournament in the
Zurich just a couple of weeks ago
against kawana yeah but why term here
plates III and Reagan trying to keep
more pieces on the board and not
simplify too much coyoacán just castles
not that just to complete this this
overview note that what is ill advised
to take here because of this funny move
like threatening mate and threatening to
win the night just to show that the
5-pound is safe c3 and now castles yeah
again you can ask what happens if white
decides to be greedy the point is that
after this um like it's playing d5 a
very quick opening of the center and
white is in some trouble here already he
needs to think badly about equalizing
you can absolutely not grab even more
material here Queenie atis real problem
so what shouldn't be greedy he just
canceled which is a wise decision and
kayaking plays d 60 a very classical set
up by the by the black player which
could have easily
be the same set up against the Italian
game yeah like in the bishop on c4 here
it is on b5 other than that it could
easily um yeah it's a very similar type
of structure yeah the interesting move
here however is 92 and the next one I
black 92 it's very normal kayaking now
plays 97 this move wasn't well known a
couple of years ago but um yeah it has
become popular and it's in my mind a
very good way to play for black yeah why
is that why should he move the night
second time there is a good reason for
that the thing is that the night if he
put it back on c6 is severely limited by
the pawns on Caesar by the policy three
the night is not doing so much it looks
at squares that are are controlled by
white very often this is a problem piece
for black he really likes to regroup it
and g6 is a good place so why not 97
black intense 96 and we'll play c6 to
win a tempo on whites bishop sometimes
you get a completely symmetrical
position out of that for example if
white now play something like that just
have a look note that in this case it's
even black who has won a temper because
c6 Bishop c4 happened so two moves to go
to see for this is blacks general idea
i'm putting the night on g6 and play c6
and why did this scheme or ever didn't
play look you only try to do something
immediately played deform striking in
the center yeah now we see blacks idea
obviously he does not want to retreat
this gives a b5 he wants to end needs to
take and now we treat at first sight
this looks rather dubious why would
flick em give
the center but it has some reason um it
has some reasoning behind it to the idea
is to play d5 and we see this soon this
is this whole setup but black is some
viable because of the somewhat awkward
position of the bishop on b5 and the
night on D to the night would be on xiii
for example this is far less interesting
blacks play but here look at this white
played h3 very sensible moopheus Bishop
g4 as a potential set up so he prevents
that after d5 now now e5 this is
necessary if Y term elects to take black
has a very nice position against the
isolated pawn where whites pieces and
this key pieces a night on d 2 and on b5
are both misplaced if white wants to
fight for anything lagging in water she
needs to play me five and now nitey form
so we see that black has managed to um
yeah alter the central pawn structure he
has centralized this night nicely only
for the night only seven has potential
on the King side and black has on the
later stage c5 available to further take
the center so i really like the setup
for black i think it's a very nice way
to to develop he now played Bishop d3
under aiken did yeah the bishop is not
doing much on b5 he at least text the
night okay i can now place no that's a
bit too much just Bishop f5 yeah it
protects the night that introduces some
technical possibilities because this is
just unprotected this this Bishop so why
it must be a lot you cannot play em like
let's say three because of night f2 and
black is almost winning the game or
so white must react to that and he did
he played Queenie two very natural move
and this also intends to win a pawn so
blacks next move is basically frost but
it is completely sufficient you played
the light back to c6 yeah now it's
simply a different situation then when
he moved it away just six moves ago now
on c6 the night is not looking at the
porn on c3 but it looks at deform and
make some very serious pressure on this
weak spot yeah it's actually two times
attacked and how should white cover it
if white now we decide on a passive move
to to cover it might be three for
example we would now have on the board a
game that was played last year between
Peter swidler and Alvin love me one of
the top touch players after f6 lemme had
a decent position he attacked the center
there's also an alternative which also
I'm sorry 93 there's also a 5 which i
also like trying to yeah kick the night
away and with f6 later Black has very
decent pressure i really like black ears
villa later won the game but it happened
later min and long end game so it it was
not related to the opening black is
completely fine here however Knight b3
is probably the move you need to play if
you want to fight i am and drake in now
plate rook to d1 and this basically
except a complete accepts a complete
clearance of the center Black now has a
move that
that basically kills the game and kayak
and decides to do that it takes on d4
with a cell Bishop a knight takes was
also possible look at this something
like that is also possibility or should
lead to two equal play the game we took
with the bishop and now after night
takes he takes e4 there should be four
at first it looks a bit awkward for
black because he's got this standoff
between the rook and the Queen on yet
but it does not seem to be a big problem
after Bishop before you buy white he
even captured and now we see the idea if
wide now recaptures there's Bishop takes
f2 and like even wince the exchange and
the game so we cannot do that right must
take here on d form which leads to
further exchanges after 3d at five what
black could not do black could not take
here this is leading to problems it's a
pin and you have no discover check after
c5 do should be three white were here
win a pawn on d4 so black does not have
any choice really must play Queen to d5
but that's also a good move this
introduces this idea 'if I've is hanging
yeah and why term does not really have
much else he took on c6 qui takes and f3
stopping the diagonal pressure like II
needed to retreat it to d5 and now be
three yeah we see that we have some some
trades um in the position there are only
opposite colored bishops left and in
fact it's one of those positions where
both bishops don't have much scope why
term can put
Bishop on be too low 1 a 3 weight it
takes nothing on the long diagonal right
we'll always look at the UM porn and
blacks bishop hmm it's also basically
biting on granite everything's nicely
protected after a five Bishop e3 route
28 taxi one will be six chicken yeah we
had some further moves but it's simply a
really dead position very difficult to
make any sort of headway and there's
even some yeah some some some leeway for
for for an accurate played solution yet
wrong they exchanged a bit more check
can now can't for this repetition to
wrap the game up so what can you say
it's a dog game you don't have great
games all the time and this is one of
those rather dull draws and it is
however theoretically interesting for
players who play the Berlin defense
which you might say oh why should I play
the bullet isn't this a somewhat boring
opening yeah well it's not like an auto
shop opening that's clear but it's an
opening for black player very much
suited for black player who wants to to
get a game going and wants to um yeah
fight in Long games playable just on my
end games and on the other hand does not
want to get involved in any heavy
theoretical preparation because
especially if you consider that you're
not playing on a world championship
level you play this against them a
player which is similar and strength to
you or reason slightly better maybe you
have very good chances to get a playable
game
and you won't get out prepared or
anything you just have a game of chess
to play which is I think a good thing
it's not like you need to learn their
hearts force moves and and and and stuff
this makes it interesting choice I think
for the amateur player who does not mind
as mentioned somewhat technical or over
here sometimes a bit I've been
simplified positions like in the boolean
endgame important is that d3 is played
off and really and this position here
black can can easily get against all
kinds of opposition and here this 97
move is an interesting way to play that
maybe a black player should should
consider in in their own games all right
i hope you liked it anyway it's a it
simply as mentioned you cannot have
those kind of epic battles every day
thanks for watching